hi i'm lola tong and i play belly in the
summer i turn pretty hey i'm sean
kaufman and i play steven hey there i'm
chris briney i play conrad hey i'm gavin
castellano and i play jeremiah and we're
the cast of the summer i turn pretty and
we're here with buzzfeed to take a quiz
to see which character we are
steve conrad
[Music]
first how would your friends describe
you romantic shy
kind or resourceful i think you're kind
i think you're kind
of
i said let's let's click it for each
other
i'm going to toss up between romantic
and kind but because everyone's choosing
kind of you're pretty romantic gavin
chris i think you're a little shy but
you're also kind i mean you're both kind
people we're all kind i think all four
of us
lead with lead with empathy you know and
that lends itself to kindness what if we
all
that would be so romantically
i did kind i don't know all right
romantic for the next one it's pick a
famous love triangle
uh it's between oh laura jean peter
kavinsky and john ambrose into all the
boys p.s i still love you shout out
jenny han jenny
jenny han katniss peter and gail
on the hunger games bella
edward and jacob and twilight uh davey
paxton and ben and never have i ever
this is hard i'm gonna go with uh
katniss peeta and gayle i just feel like
i love the adventure i love that
triangle and there's so much action in
it so that's amazing i grew up on that
that's what i grew true true i'm gonna
have to go with uh lara jean peter and
john ambrose i feel like those movies
are so sweet and shout out to jenny
obviously so i'm gonna i'm gonna go with
with that love triangle yeah i can't do
that because i auditioned for john
ambrose and i didn't get it so this is
this is the second jenny conroll day
i'ma pick bella edward and jacob and
twilight but only for that one scene
where they're all play like baseball
baseball yeah bro i'm gonna pick it for
the same reason yeah that's on par yeah
that part's golf kevin
what is your favorite summertime
activity going to the beach reading by
the pool
riding your bike or having a barbecue
reading by the pool then maybe
yeah bro having a barbecue though think
of all the activities that come with
that that's fun but going to the beach
is the same thing all the activity no no
no no no you can't play wiffle ball on
the beach because it's too windy but you
can play wiffle ball at a barbecue what
beach are you going to what
barbecue beaches are windy like that's
part of the tend to be windy yeah i
think going to the beach because we had
so much fun on the beach this summer
like that's what i think of we had such
a such a blast okay i don't know how i'm
supposed to react to this i think the
belly answer is writing here but no i
don't know what the belly answer is oh
you are you trying
i was gonna say going to the beach or
riding a bike belly loves to do all
those things that's why they're here
true i'm gonna go
riding your bike it's how i used to
memorize my lines i would bike down to
the pier and like that's nice yeah
that's so
you're lying
order an ice cream flavor from scoops
vanilla chocolate strawberry and
chocolate chip i'm definitely picking
chocolate pens because if it's like a
french vanilla like if it's like one of
the vanilla
that's what i'm saying but it doesn't
say vanilla bean chris she's under the
subcategory right there's a lot of
subcategories
no sub category so you're saying it can
be mint chocolate chip that has to be
chocolate
chocolate
it's vanilla chocolate strawberry and
chocolate chip christopher i'm still
going vanilla i'm i'm st i'm still going
vanilla
yes sir boring i'm going chocolate chip
i like that little bit of crunch that's
why i love
nestle crunch
pick a character from the summer i
turned pretty to spend the day with
susannah laurel taylor or cam cameron i
kind of want to pick laurel cause she's
so wonderful but belly probably wouldn't
make laurel not that i'm trying to but
just from that perspective i'm gonna go
with laurel i think you know
surprisingly enough i'm gonna go with
taylor because she knows like how to
party how to have fun she would be the
life of the party and i feel like we
would get into so many mischievous fun
things together i get that choose a
summary movie to watch at the drive-in
grease
in the heights
jaws or lilo and stitch which i didn't
know was a movie what didn't know that
was a movie what do you mean isn't it a
tv show this man also doesn't know
until two hours ago john's not gonna
pick up
i gotta pick jaws man you know i was
that's fizzy i'm not for that i'm sorry
yeah
classics
i'm gonna say greece greece is like i'm
a musical girl but also i love in the
heights as a musical and the movie was
really sweet yeah so i kind of want to
go with knights yeah but over the
popularization of the dolly zoom like
yeah but john travolta okay
yeah i just i like the music in in the
heights and it's just such a fun yeah no
and new york i'm gonna go with the
knights finally choose a song to dance
with your crush two at the debutante
ball lover by taylor swift uh as it was
by harry styles about damn time by lizzo
and that's what i want by little nas x
i'm gonna go with lover i won't press it
yet though because this is the last
question so i'll wait
for suspense i think if you're at a ball
though you kind of want something that
leans toward ballad i guess lover is the
most sort of about about
e of them you know i'm really stuck
between lover and as it was because i
love as it was something yeah it's a
great song that's a fun song i feel like
there'd be like a cool like
montage moment
like a spinning montage moment of
dancing all right i'm going with that
like the second to last song of the
night i think i got to go with
about damn time if i want to impress my
crush at the ball bro do you know the
tick tock dance no but i would learn it
you got to learn it in a minute i'm
anita sentimental men and women you know
what i mean i got to impress
i'm conrad fisher oh no way
are you serious yeah like conrad you're
a bit of a closed book you're incredibly
hard to read and you keep your feelings
close to the vast which means that even
the people you love most feel like they
don't really know where they stand with
you the truth is under the surface
you're incredibly vulnerable with a huge
heart and all you want is to protect the
people you care about and every once in
a while you let them care about you too
i feel like that's so funny because
didn't we all say that he was like the
furthest from
i know but that but that makes sense
that's a really sweet description i like
the description well uh
you
are
conrad fisher
wow
what
yeah i genuinely didn't expect that but
i i mean
you'll see my reaction i literally hope
i did not expect that but yeah jeremiah
no way let's go
maybe it's a sibling thing then yeah
like jeremiah you have a heart of gold
and a smile as bright as the sun
you also have a big personality and
you're not afraid to speak your mind or
make sure that people in your life know
exactly how you feel about them and of
course you're a total social butterfly
people just flock to you and your
irresistible charm it's very sweet oh
that's so cute we are one you were one
it's very fitting it's a very fitting
end i feel like yeah yeah
bye thank you so much everybody having
us buzzfeed thank you for watching let
us know what you you got and make sure
to tune in to prime video to watch the
summer i turn pretty tune in
i'm gonna try to get every character
later
[Music]
[Music]
you